in my adult life there's only been two
revolutionary technologies in i.t
one of those is the web the other
revolutionary technology are distributed
ledgers what we commonly call blockchain
why i think that's revolutionary is that
the distributed ledger technology of the
blockchain technology
allows us to share data in a
tamper-proof way
so the data can be shared in a way that
we can guarantee
that it won't be altered won't be
altered by the sender of the data it
won't be altered by an intermediary and
it won't be altered by the recipient and
this turns out to be really important in
lots and lots of applications
most people will have seen something in
the title here relating to blockchain
and straight away they jump to the
conclusion that we're talking
cryptocurrency
um is that the case
not necessarily so
so the blockchain the first blockchain
that was developed was for bitcoin some
of the other videos give you a good
technical explanation of how it works
what's interesting to me is that the
technology was novel but its components
were not novel the components were
things that already existed in different
parts of computer science and what was
novel was the particular way they were
put together the particular engineering
it turns out there are lots of other
applications besides cryptocurrencies
i think the first ones that people
realized were also to do with currencies
foreign exchange trading i helped myself
and some students helped a major global
bank develop a prototype system
for
foreign exchange trading internally
within the bank
uh and that was so to see if they could
use uh blockchain platform internal
blockchain platform to avoid having to
use swift transactions uh people saw
those applications they then thought
well maybe we can store other
information or we can trade we can
use this platform for transactions on
other things
virtual assets or physical assets
it turns out if you're
worried about tamper-proof data
information that can't alter then it
turns out another whole class of
applications are to do with promises
how do you store a promise in a way that
it can't be altered that the person who
made the promise can't deny later or
repudiate later that they made the
promise that if there's a counter
promise or a reward for that promise
that can't be repudiated
where where do we find applications of
promises in the business world
insurance insurance is just a simple
well usually not simple a complicated
combination of promises i promise to pay
a premium to the insurance company every
month
and the insurance company in return
promises to pay me a large sum of money
if my house burns down and under some
under some agreement about what what the
conditions are so we've made some
interlocking promises
how can i be sure they will follow
through
particularly how can i be sure if the
insurance company goes broke and the
policy gets bought by another firm or
what happens in the longer term
conceptually there's no difference
between storing a promise on some data
platform between storing any information
so we get applications that involve uh
for example the french ministry of
education has an application where it
keeps a record at every degree issued by
a higher education institution in france
so that employers can check when an
applicant says i've got a degree from
the subon the employers can check
whether they actually do have a degree
and when it was awarded and and so on
and that's data that is not going to be
it's not transactions it's just data
that's going to be stored and stored one
hopes permanently
so there's a lot of publicity well
there's also the marketing side of this
right which is you know and we've seen
xkcd comics about this you know the idea
of
okay we've got this new idea and what's
great about it is got a blockchain and
that's just the marketing department for
people with that view in mind there's
lots of
there's lots of data there's lots of
grist for the mill if you like so the
example of the long island iced tea
company might come to mind that was a
company in long island that made uh
fruit juices and beverages
and uh some years ago they they've i
think they're more than a century old
this company uh some years ago their
share price was languishing and they had
the inspired idea to change the name of
the company from the long island iced
tea company to the long island ice tea
and blockchain company and suddenly
their share price went through the roof
why did that happen it partly happened
because there's lots of algorithmic
trading there's trading by computer
programs and those programs have been
coded to look for certain keywords
blockchain being a hot topic that was
one of the key words so people
programs tried to buy shares in this and
the share price went up
to my knowledge they still haven't done
anything in blockchain i might be wrong
but they they share price rows without
them having to do anything in blockchain
just by the change of name
and a cynical person could easily think
that that's that's that's this is all
hype and there are lots of there's lots
of scams there's lots of fraudulent
activity in this whole space
there's also lots of genuine business
uh development people say why go to all
this trouble to have
uh complicated technologies like
distributed ledgers
and from a technical perspective
many of the criticisms are valid so
if you were just looking at technical
perspective you might easily say we
won't go for this complicated newfangled
distributed ledges especially given all
the height we'll get we'll just go for a
centralized database and we'll put a
dedicated team in charge of that
there are two reasons why companies
don't do that and the reasons are not
technical the reasons one is legal and
regulatory the other is commercial
the legal and regulatory reason is that
most
western countries most countries in fact
now
have laws in place that prohibit what's
called anti-trust behavior
laws that encourage competition between
companies
one consequence of those laws and
regulations is that companies
generally have to be careful about what
data they share with competitors
i have seen blockchain projects where
even to have the first meeting of
companies who are in one industry for
example in the oil industry might say
we have this business process that
involves all of us we've got oil
companies we've got commodities
traders we've got banks we've got
insurance companies so let's have a
meeting let's sit down together
before they can have a meeting they have
to check with their lawyers because
having the meeting might be uh might be
a restraint of trade might be seen as an
anti-trust behavior and in my experience
generally what happens is they
before they have that first meeting
companies have to sit down and agree a
statement
among themselves with their lawyers
about what the meeting is for and what
can be said and what can't be said and
i've heard this quite often such a
statement is read out at the beginning
of the meetings and it says we're here
to discuss the sharing of data in a
technical platform we're not here to
discuss pricing and we're not here to
discuss strategy and if anyone does
they'll be expelled from the meeting and
that sounds onerous but it's required so
if you're looking at an architecture for
sharing data across some industry no
single company in this group of
companies can be the company that holds
the data either they all have the same
data and they share it and we have to do
that in such a way that they don't see
their competitors information or we give
it to a third party so we could give it
to an accounting firm or a law firm or a
tech firm to run the platform and
administer it centrally so we don't need
this distributed ledger nonsense giving
it to a third party leads you to the
second reason which is a commercial
reason why companies have opted for
distributed ledger platforms having this
pool of data under your control means
you can make money from it if a group of
companies have given the task of pooling
that data to an accounting firm then
who's going to get the benefit from
monetizing it and the group of companies
would say well we don't want that
accounting firm to get the benefit we
want ourselves to get the benefit and
that will be most easily done if we are
the owners if we are the ones who
run and run this database
that leads to lots of technical
challenges these these technologies are
still relatively new still relatively
immature we still don't have good
languages and tools that that will come
and we'll look back in 10 20 years time
we look back at
how hard it was to develop distributed
ledgers
technically how hard it was to design
how few people there are
there were at this time who have the
skills and
uh
good news for developers bad news for
anyone else is how
high the salaries are still for
developers of blockchain platforms those
salaries will come down as more people
are are skilled but that's still there's
still a technical challenge in designing
them
in in making the work when the tools the
software engineering tools are still
to be developed
another big challenge is how you manage
data access so we have a platform that
might be shared between 20 companies
they might do transactions two companies
or three companies out of the 20 you
might be doing transactions the oil
company might trade with another oil
company or make a futures contract with
another company and for this oil that's
going to be delivered in rotterdam in
three months time
and one of those companies the receiving
company wants to commission
an inspection company to go and inspect
their oil to make sure it's the right
color quality before it's unloaded that
receiving company wants to give
permission to the
inspection company to have some
information about where the deal is
going to happen how much oil is involved
what the required level of quality is
supposed to be etc they don't want to
give permission for all the data they
just want to give permission for some of
the data
they want the permission to be just for
a specific purpose
for usually for a specific period of
time
they want it to lapse after that period
of time they might want the inspection
company to
have the power to give
further
rights to someone else to a
subcontractor or to an employee for
example so we have all sorts of
uh giving of permissions to access
particular things
uh which is
much more dynamic than and much more
decentralized than is traditional in the
part of computer scientists it's
compared to computer science that looks
at access control so perhaps the most
common method of access control
in use in it commerciality is what's
called role-based access control so we
give people
access to data or access to systems
based on their role and the general
assumption
made with the deployment of these
systems is that roles don't change very
often but in this dynamic agile world of
blockchain distributed ledgers in
commercial world we want these this
needs to be a lot more dynamic it needs
to be
decentralized so we don't have a single
party in charge we have all the nodes
having equal abilities to do things
they need to be able to allocate rights
to data that those who receive the
rights can then allocate again
under some constraints they need the
rights need to be revocable there needs
to be a lot more ease and a lot more
user friendliness about allocating and
revoking rights and controlling rights
and i think the theory of access control
is still catching up with the practice
of
of this in distributed ledger world the
big it companies are
developing methods that work with regard
to dynamic delay dynamic delegatable
revocable decentralized access control
but i don't think we have that yet in
the theories of access control i'm happy
to be corrected if any any of the
readers any of the viewers
uh
um i don't want to talk about this
there you go so here we have different
quadrupeds today we're gonna see the
spot one yeah just to give an idea of
where we traveled
this is all the way from where we were
before here with the
round table